well a transformation to an iconic
property in downtown las vegas yeah
jeremy j ford is at main street in
fremont for the unveiling of a new look
for the plaza hotel and casino it's the
re-imagination of main street as the
plaza hotel and casino announces plans
for a modernized experience right here
where we're sitting under these famous
lights will be the carousel bar
plaza hotel casino ceo jonathan jossel
is giving the property an upgrade with
four new additions including pink box
donuts added casino floor space and
rooftop dining at oscars well this has
always been an iconic location this is
one main street this is where vegas
began these lights are very famous
they're iconic and we wanted to give
people something else to do here right
now it's just a porta casher it's still
going to be the entrance but we're going
to pedestrianize it there's so much
happening that we wanted to join in on
the fun and give more reason to come
downtown the plaza will also be downtown
las vegas's first smoke-free and social
media-friendly gaming space jeremy j
ford live local now the revitalization
of the plaza hotel and casino set to be
complete by the end of the year